وبتزامنه مع انضمامه فنلندا الى الناتو
يعقد وزراء خارجات الحل في اجتماعا
لمناقشه تطور انتشار المجموعات القتاليه
التي نشرها الحلف فيما يسمى بالجناح
الشرقي التي يضم دولا كان معظمها جزءا من
الاتحاد السوفيتي السابق وتخشى تعرض لهجوم
روسي كما يبحث الوزراء ملف نشري روسيا
رؤوسا نوويه قرب حدود دول البلطيق
والاستعداد لقمه الحلف في ليتوانيا
المقرره في شهر يونيو المقبل
الينا من امامي مقر حلف الناتو في بروكسيل
مراسل الجزيره محمد البقالي وينضم الينا
منها لسانكي مراسل الجزيره محمد المدهون
ابدا معك البقالي يوم تاريخي مثل ما وصفه
مع انضمام عضو جديد
لتوضعنا في اجواء هذا اليوم التاريخي كما
تعيشه
هناك احتفاليه احتفال واحتفاء بهذا
الانضمام هذا كان واضحا من تصريحات الامين
العام لحلف شماليه
الذي اكد بالفعل بان هذا اليوم يوم تاريخي
ستنظم بعد قليل احتفاليه هنا في هذا
المكان في مقر حلف النيتو حيث سيتم رفع
العلم الفنلندي لاول مره على مقر حلف
النيتو الى جانب اعلام الدول الثلاثين
الاخرى بحضور الرئيس الفنلندي الامير
العام لحلف الشماليه الاطلسيه عبر عن هذا
الاحتفاء بالقول ان فنلندا اصبحت اامن بعد
هذا الانضمام وحلف النيت اصبح اقوى فنلندا
اصبحت عمل لانه قال انها من الان فصاعدا
فهي تتمتع بمظله الحمايه التي يوفرها حلف
النيتو الذي يمتلك نصف القوه العسكريه في
الكره الارض على وفق تعبيره عمليا الان في
اللاندا تستفيد من هذه الحمايه وبالتالي
فان اي اعتداء على فنلندا هو بمثابه على
اعتداء كل الدول وهذا يعني وفقا للماده
الخامسه ان تتداعى كل الدول لحمايه فنلندا
او اي دوله اخرى النيتو سيكون اقوى وفقا
لحلف وفقا للامين لامينه العام لان النيتو
يرى في هذه الخطوه انتصارا رمزيا على
روسيا لان روسيا انما هجمت اوكرانيا بسبب
رغبتها في الانضمام الى الحلف الان الحلف
بضمه لي فنلندا
يقترب اكثر او يزيد من حدوده مع روسيا ل
1300 كيلومتر اضافيه اي ما يمثل ضعف
الحدود التي كانت تربط الحلف مع روسيا وهو
ما كانت لا ترغب فيه روسيا وهو الامر الذي
كان يزعج روسيا التي كانت ترفض اقتراب
الحلف من حدودها هناك نوع من التحدي ونوع
من العقاب في هذه الخطوه وهذا هو ما نلمسه
لدى الاطراف الدبلوماسيه المشاركه هنا
التي تعبر عن نشوه النصر والتاكيد على ان
الحلف ماض في ضم دول اخرى على راسها
السويد التي قدمت ملف ترشيحها مع فنلندا
ولكنها ما زالت تواجه اعتراضا تركيا
ومجريا تركيا تعترض بسبب موقفها من
استقبال السويد لما تصفه تركيا بمجموعات
ارهابيه والمجر لديها اعتراضات اذا تتعلق
بالانتقادات التي وجهتها لها السويد بخصوص
ديمقراطيتها والتزامها بحقوق الانسان ولكن
الامين العام ريح الشمالي لا تلصقها بان
هذه الخلافات سيتم تبديدها وان السويد
ستلتحق قريبا بالحلف ويبدو ان العمل جاري
على هذا الامر ليس ذلك فقط ولكن الاميره
العام قال ان الحلف مفتوح لكل الدول
الديمقراطيه بما يعني الرغبه في توسيع
الحلف ضد على اراده روسيا وعقابا لها
واضافه او تقويه لموقع الحلف في مواجهه ما
يوصف بالتهديد